la vague vegan pousse les industriels de
l'alimentation à imiter de plus en plus
de produits traditionnels les fromages
sans produits laitiers sont très
populaires d'ailleurs l'an dernier aux
états unis
on a remarqué une augmentation de 43%
des ventes dans ce segment
nous sommes aujourd'hui au marché
jean-talon justement pour faire goûter
4,6 lily fromage à la crème des textures
est quand même très
est ce que ce genre de produit vers
lequel vous iriez naturellement ou pas
ou non découvrez-vous ça ressemble à du
fromage
pas vraiment du promeneur les hommages à
la crise et des fromages végétaux qui
sont faites soit à base de noix ou de
graines ou encore à base d'huile le défi
de reproduire un fromage végétal qui va
d'abord une texture similaires ou
fromage à la crème c'est au niveau de la
texture donc dans les ingrédients on va
avoir des fois de la protéine de poids
la crème de coco des pois chiches aussi
donc différence agents qui vont me
permettre d'avoir une texture laisser
creamers qui nous rappelle fromage à la
crème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas trop mal maintenant j'ai pas
de l'incroyable la centrale tout comme
le fêtard plupart te rendrais que je les
fais moins dans la bouche et qui
promettait beaucoup à prouver
ouais ici j'ai le earth island on va
voir que c'est un produit qui est quand
même assez riche en gras saturés l'on
sait que les gras saturés s'est associé
à moins de bonne santé cardiovasculaire
côté gras saturés ceux qui sont faits à
base d'huile mais avoir quand même une
teneur assez élevé en gras saturés
tout comme ceux à base de lait de vache
à puisieux à base de noix généralement
sont plus pauvres en gras saturés
[Musique]
entre alice et le bleu ce que tu aimes
les côtés
la vanille c'est bon ouais ouais ouais
les saveurs jamoye
précieux sur le coup
earth et du père ans a dû verser comme
du beurre oui
classé sous le crachin produit c'est le
dail acquis et la tartine âme ou simili
fromage à la crème on à la version 1
nature ici le premier d'ingrédients
c'est de l'eau ensuite c'est l'huile de
noix de coco l'amidon tapioca je
pourrais continuer y en a quand même
quelques uns ont donc on est aussi en
présence d'un aliment qui est ultra
transformé avec une longue et
d'ingrédients côté fait des protéines
c'est pas très élevé donc si on mange
chaud pour déjeuner un fromage à la
crème kremer faudrait le manger sur du
pain complet donc un pain intégral qui
vont nous donner aussi des protéines
peut-être accompagné aussi avec une
boisson de soya pour s'assurer d'avoir
un déjeuner rassasiant
un petit goût de noisette qui est pas
oui ça passe
il doit
un petit coup de cidre
[Musique]
as aimé
fort ben moi je consulterai aussi ça
coûte un peu la foi de test le fromage à
la crème de noix de cajou non les filles
watson qui est un fromage végétal qui
est fait à montréal
ici on est en présence vraiment d'un
fromage végétal qui est pas trés
transformer le hong anh ou à laquelle
jours au filtre et culture d'enzymes et
celle de mr quatre ingrédients
c'est simple on pourrait prendre les
mêmes ingrédients pu faire nous mêmes à
la maison donc ce en partant j'aime ça
on y vend aussi
palm a l'habitude
salez savez quoi
en tout cas base de
fois-çi je suis mis quelque chose
ça s'écoute comme le hummus quatrième
produit qui est le kremer nature de
legrand il va être un petit peu moins
caloriques du fait que le premier
ingrédient c'est à bordeaux
ensuite moi de quel jour pois chiches
crème de noix de coco c'est le demeure à
granulés et culture lactique
donc c'est un produit qui est aussi
fermenté avec la culture bactérienne
bonnes bactéries aime bien les aliments
fermentés puis en plus de cela un
bénéfice au niveau du goût savoureux
aussi le goût que ça va donner un
fromage qui va avoir un peu plus de
caractère plus la plupart des produits
étaient généralement assez salée mais
ceux-ci typique d'un fromage qui soit
partir du lait de vache ou qu'ils soient
à partir de noir ou divine donc c'était
assez similaire lesquels vous préférez
parmi ces quatre nouveaux magistrats
puis c'est le deuxième
choisir un produit qui va être à base de
noix de cajou parce que ça va être
justement un fromage végétal qui vont
être faits à partir d'ingrédients entier
donc peu transformés donc je laisserai
de côté les fromages à base d'huile qui
paraît plus proche d'un produit le
trotteur de transformer ce qui est moins
associée à une bonne santé dont 50 vous
tord se sont prononcés résulte un trois
produits sont arrivés presque ex aequo
mais le grain gagnant aujourd'hui si je
peux dire est justement le faux marge de
mac le grain produits du québec merci à
tous et à toutes
intéressant